Eh,
Hey,
last time we saw how romance verbs use different endings to point out the person
performing the action.
They also have one of four thematic vowels inside the ending depending on the
verbs.
Conjugations.
Yep.
To now,
we've only taken one slice of time.
The present come pass or can Thomas are in the present tense.
Pence is just an old French word.
That means time.
Consider another time,
another tents.
The past tense.
Latin verbs had a longer set of endings in the past.
I'm a sport you love,
but I'm,
are we Steve for you loved similarly a month versus I'm awaiting
but vulgar Latin shorten these endings.
A Masti Amato,
so Portuguese speakers say a mash to an Amato and Italian has I'm and Amato.
This tense gets called by other names.
Predator,
it historic past simple,
past remote past in France,
Italy and Switzerland.
Romance speakers use a different way of talking about the past.
At least in everyday language.
They say the equivalent of you have sung for you saying so we hear national t
icon Tato yes,
they're important,
but let's revisit these constructions later.
We learned six forms of the verb in the present,
gone through Qantas contact.
Thomas can patties content.
There are six more forums in the past.
[inaudible]
die.
Contrasty come thought fantastic.
Kentaro stay in the past tense for a moment,
but inject the concept of aspect.
Aspect is how we're,
how often a verb is done.
It's the simple distinction or romance.
One time completed verbs versus continuous ongoing actions.
The difference between them becomes an issue.
In the past gone Tai Chi,
fantastic.
And other past forms are simple.
Pinpoint one time,
actions.
There's another set of endings for continuous actions.
In the past like gun Tavis,
you used to sing or you were singing.
This is called the imperfect and that B is a good clue.
You're looking at I vulgar Latin,
Imperfect v day,
a bus [inaudible].
Many modern languages do lose that be at least in certain conjugations.
There's one more tense.
The future tense.
Western romance languages developed future endings by attacking the vulgar Latin
word for have to the backs of infinitives
Sardinian Romance.
Romanian and southern Italian languages didn't develop these future endings.
They didn't share in this innovation,
nor did they inherit the classical Latin future.
Instead,
they have phrases for the future as a Cantata,
they can
data
past,
present,
future three tenses.
You now have a basis for understanding how these three tenses is working,
romance,
as well as the difference between the [inaudible] and the imperfect in the
paths.